this morning in our ion money series the
last-minute rush to file tax returns
there is less than a week left for many
people to meet the April 15th deadline
Massachusetts and Maine residents have
until the 17th the IRS reports the
number of returns is down 1.4 percent
compared with this time last year the
average refund dropped $20 to just under
$2,900 that means the IRS has refunded
more than 6 billion dollars less this
year CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with what
last-minute filers need to know good
morning hi so if you're a procrastinator
what should you be doing well clear your
weekend schedule you know it's not going
to be fun right
so we want to make sure that you gather
up your documents and you figure out how
you're going to file the IRS says please
try to do it electronically and there's
a few different resources you know that
there are commercially available
software programs you've heard of all of
them but there's also a really great
resource the IRS provides IRS free file
if you have income of less than 66
thousand dollars it's great there's also
the fillable forms that come
pre-populated so this is a good idea I
know if you've got a complicated
situation the idea could be I must find
somebody but with a week to go I think
finding a person who you can actually
sit down with is gonna be tough so 2018
returns are the first tax returns right
since the tax cuts and job backs and I
saw that one accounted was quoted
account was quoted in the New York Times
as saying this is the most complicated
tax season ever
so was it gotten harder well you know
for some people yes and for some people
no I think it's confusing we see that
irs.gov website visits are up by more
than 10 percent from last year I think
people are kind of worried about that
but remember part of this has to do with
the way you're filing if you file
claiming the standard deduction it may
not be as hard as you are thinking it's
going to be and looks like there's going
to be about 85 90 % of tax filers who
will claim that standard deduction
because it more than doubled with the
new tax law if you're an itemized er it
is going to be hard and you've got to
work your way through it but again don't
freak yourself out this is one of those
things where if you just plod through it
you will get through it
so one
in ten people apparently file for
extensions there's nothing morally wrong
with that
[Laughter]
so is that extraordinary why is that and
and by the way if you're freaking out
about meeting the deadline is an
extension an okay thing to do it's a
great thing to do and it's not very hard
to do but I want to remind everyone this
is incredibly important the IRS will
give you six extra months to file the
IRS does not give you six extra months
to pay sorry John you've got to pay what
you think you owe or you will face
penalties but you know listen you file
the form with the IRS you go on the
extension but remember two other things
one is if you are going to make an IRA
contribution you've got to make that by
the deadline you cannot go on extension
with that unless it's a SEP IRA and
again please try to estimate what you
owe this is incredibly important you
better to overestimate what you owe than
underestimate but to John's point it's
not morally wrong no it's good thank you
financial and spiritual advice